[Music]
juwan howard the new coach of the
michigan men's basketball program one of
the members of the fab five from nearly
30 years ago my god it's been that long
but it is a homecoming for juwon howard
and look folks this time of year we're
looking for any ideas we can to
springboard a pft live draft so how
about this one we haven't done this one
before at least if we have we don't
remember it best homecomings in the nfl
this is broad this can be anything that
you can manage to make a persuasive case
it is a homecoming chris sims so i hope
you're ready i got the impression during
the break you haven't done a lot of
research for this one and i did so i
should just go ahead and let you have
the first pick but you know because when
you have the first pick you usually blow
it so do you want to take the first pick
do we want it to go through that's all
right i got enough i just wasn't sure i
was all over the place with what
homecoming qualified as so i got enough
here i'm not worried about you be quiet
okay let's go to the coin toss okay i
don't want it right and i'm gonna pick
heads because i think she's gonna feel
sorry for you and i'm gonna get the
first pick anyway why should she feel
sorry for him i kicked your ass all week
we are crazy i don't pick murderers and
you do we have standards on my team
okay alleged murderers go ahead all
right first one here it's actually a
tough decision about where i want to go
here the first one though i'm gonna go
brett favre going back to green bay in
2009. i think that's the one that leads
the list to me as far as homecoming i
mean brett favre
arguably the greatest quarterback in
green bay history kind of held it over
their heads for years i'm going to
retire i'm going to play i'm going to
retire i'm going to play okay he finally
green bay draws a line in the sand and
says no we're moving on we got aaron
rodgers he goes and plays for the jets
in 2008 but he doesn't have to play
against green bay 2009 he signs with the
rival minnesota vikings and i just can
still remember the week you know i just
remember i was still playing in the nfl
of course and just the buzz around that
game and that situation brett favre
going back to green bay you know in
purple and white uh that was just an
amazing moment to me and one i didn't
ever expect to see brett favre in a
different uniform two i certainly didn't
expect them to be in minnesota and of
course that was the year they went on
the run and he won the game that night i
believe if i remember correctly but to
me that's one of the more memorable
homecomings i can remember just right
off the top of my head wait a minute
wait a minute it's a memorable home
coming and you don't remember whether or
not he won the game i'm pretty sure i
don't look up the statistics like that i
just go off the top i'm such a historian
they they they won the game see i knew
it and
he was booed mercy every time he was on
the field and every time he touched the
ball and every time i mean all game long
but yes the vikings swept the packers
that year and the vikings almost
parlayed that into a super bowl
appearance but for brett favre throwing
the ball across his body and tracy
porter intercepting it late in
regulation in new orleans the vikings
may very well have you okay all right
were they sure where they inaudibly
would have lost to the indianapolis
colts i don't know that would have been
awesome though
speaking of super bowls and this is the
ultimate nfl homecoming because it was
so ridiculously over the top all we
heard for two weeks was that jerome
bettis is from detroit did you know
jerome bettis is from detroit hey by the
way the steelers playing the super bowl
in detroit and jerome bettis is from
detroit yes we know jerome bettis is
from detroit well he returned to detroit
for what was the final game of his
career won a super bowl walked off into
the sunset with the trophy at that
homecoming game farf simply won when he
went back to green bay and it really
wasn't his home it was his pro football
home for betis it was his hometown last
game of his career super bowl win no
better way to cap it and over the top
jerome bettis is from detroit for two
weeks that's clearly the number one pick
in this draft chris especially because
it's michigan and we used michigan as
the launching point that's another
reason it's the clear no-brainer first
pick i mean it's cool it's a great story
i don't know if it's as cool as some of
the other ones we're gonna pick here
it's it's got the greatest ending
because it's the super bowl i get that
but it's not like he was going into
you're making my case stronger well it
wasn't to me it's not a true homecoming
you know what i mean i don't for this
what was his home i i guess he wasn't
born
michigan no so then maybe we should
throw this draft out of the list he's
not living in michigan go ahead okay
you're just trying to concede you're
such a lawyer be quiet okay my next
one's marcus allen okay because i
remember this when i was a young kid
marcus allen going back to play the los
angeles raiders in 1993 as a member of
the kansas city chiefs again another
star hall of fame type player going to
play for a rival football team but i
think what happened before that is what
makes it so magical i mean
as we all know it's well documented al
davis marcus allen didn't like each
other uh and you can go down nfl
rumorville to why that happened or what
happened with the dysfunction of that
relationship but marcus allen started
out as the prize possession of the
oakland raiders super bowl mvp of super
bowl 18 right against the washington
redskins i mean awesome player usc
southern california just gold he is as
cool as it gets
the raiders for whatever reason al davis
benches marcus allen made him sit behind
bo jackson made him full back
disrespected him on the roster a number
of times he goes to kansas city 1993 and
becomes mr goal line touchdown running
back and the chiefs start winning
football games and joe montana is a
quarterback and uh of course that to me
as a little kid i can still remembering
that because not only was it marcus
allen but
we felt like there was true hate between
al davis and marcus allen with the the
particular subject there
oh i mean anytime you deliberately put a
guy on the bench for multiple years you
put him on ice you're paying him to not
play and then he finally gets a chance
to get away and he comes back to haunt
you that is that is a good story but
there are still better stories and this
next one that this is a special
dedication to our coordinating producer
matt casey he is going to hate this so i
love it even more and and even though
the memories have faded in 2011 one of
the biggest stories in football was
tebow mania and even though he never did
anything after the 2011 season he did
take the denver broncos to the final
eight he did throw a first drive
touchdown pass to damarius thomas right
and that all started that all started
with his homecoming to the state of
florida now i know that the first game
of tebow mania was in south florida not
in gainesville but if you recall chris
on that day
for whatever reason at the miami
dolphins stadium it was florida gator
alumni day so it was a perfect
storm of circumstance and here's tim
tebow getting his first opportunity down
15 points in the fourth quarter leads
the broncos back and that was the first
and i remember watching that in the nbc
viewing room and we went nuts it was
unbelievable there were so many games
that year where there's no way the
broncos are going to win this game and
here comes tim tebow working magic
digging the team out of a hole that he
dug for it because he was so bad in the
past three and a half quarters right but
that was it all started on that day in
south florida when it was the florida
gators alumni day and a florida gator
alumnus
stole the heart out of that chest of the
miami dolphins so that to me that i'll
never forget that day i i mean i i
remember it too of course i do um i mean
wow i just what a horrible pick holy cow
i mean i just want you just cemented the
draft for me i won it right there go
ahead
that's all you got jens and the stars
when all you say when all you say is
that was a horrible pick and you give no
basis for it i know that i rattled my
picture brett favre and marcus allen
you're tim tebow and i don't know a fake
homecoming with jerome bettis okay here
we go my last pick to nail down my
championship okay um
this is one i'm just not sure where i
want to go here okay i'm gonna do with
this one i'm gonna go with the one i
know better how about joe gibbs coming
back to coach the washington redskins uh
after what was it a 12 year hiatus okay
i mean joe gibbs first of all
i don't think gets the credit for being
one of the all-time great coaches that
he should i mean it's a guy that won
three super bowls and brought the
redskins to four super bowls one of them
they lost to the
oakland raiders and marcus allen oddly
enough but this is an all-time legend
one of the greatest coaches in the
history of the sport he leaves the sport
and goes and you know dally's in his
nascar business and he's all into that
and i know he owned a car and i'm sure
they were kicking butt there but then to
come back and
make the playoffs his second year and uh
thank you joe your first playoff win
since you were back was against me
thanks a lot but still i think that's a
pretty cool story because i just feel
like it's very rare that a legendary
coach takes a break one
uh and comes back after that amount of
time but two to come back to the same
team i thought that's what was special
about it i mean we saw dick vermeel go
from the eagles of the rams and you know
bill parcell switched teams but joe
gibbs went back to the same team and i
thought that's why it makes it a extra
cool homecoming
i i i this is not my pick i am stunned
you did not pick otto beckham jr the day
he went back to new orleans back to
louisiana and had three touchdowns in a
52-49 shootout against the saints i'm
stunned that that wasn't one of your
picks i would have assumed going in that
would have been one of your picks it's
not big time enough i need more
grandiosity so i need bigger and that's
just one game i just i didn't these ones
i thought were bigger
well
this one i was was uh
i i think it doesn't get as much
attention as it deserves and i'm still
holding out hope that this player ends
up playing for the team that he
bedeviled that day but this was eric
barry just two years removed from a
cancer diagnosis and he fought back from
it he went back to his hometown of
atlanta grew up not that far from the
site of the georgia dome which was the
stadium at the time and this was 2016
and this is a defensive player who
scored eight points that day he had pick
six and he returned a two-point
conversion for the decisive score 29-28
as the chiefs beat the atlanta falcons
and i've always felt like eric berry was
destined to play for the falcons he's
been available for the past few months
he's still got that lingering issue he
had the torn achilles tendon week one of
the 2017 season didn't play at all that
year barely played in 2018. i still hold
out hope that he ends up with the
falcons and then he can make more magic
like he did that day again eric barry
not a hall of famer eric barry one of
the better defensive backs of this time
period right but that to me i remember
that it's how memorable is it to me that
was a memorable moment it was an
incredible performance for a guy who had
beaten cancer and was back home and
stuck it to that hometown team in a way
that you rarely see a defensive back
affect the outcome of a game yeah that
was pretty cool that was special i get
it and yeah i mean i'm giving you a lot
of credit for going the sentimental
route here you're trying to win the
sentimental vote here on this draft okay
but he is you know do whatever you have
to do to win but it it wasn't that was
big
right the first one was over the top and
it was it got to the point where you got
sick of hearing about jerome bettis
being from detroit but clearly when you
think homecomings that's the first one
you think of the the others i think
we're just i'll i'll never forget those
days that's not clearly the first one
you think of i'm sorry yeah it is no one
is not it's not the first one that i
thought of i just i know that and my
brain's extraordinary you know that
you have you have a great brain you use
all the best words you know it all right
the best
brett favre goes back to green bay as a
viking marcus allen faces the raiders as
a chief joe gibbs comes back to coach
washington i've got bettis finishing his
career in a detroit super bowl tebow
kicking off tebow mania at miami on
gator day and eric berry back in georgia
after the cancer battle and eight total
points scored by versus safety sims won
this draft vote for sims
when we return adam gase is going to
meet with the media today we'll talk
about what he may be asked and how he
may answer those questions when we wrap
up this thursday edition of pft library
after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports